evening all I'm with my good friend
Chris known as chess explains so it was
game six today of the world chess
championship hi Chris yeah trifon hi
okay in Game six d 4 by boris gelfand
and we saw a repeat of the Slav defense
yeah this so the Sun these kind of games
they feel a bit like a broken record
right yes yes and I'm getting a bit
concerned about symmetrical Paul
structures I had an over the board game
a few weeks ago wells I was actually
irritated the opponent played in
exchange French and I remember the
irritation I'm starting to feel the same
thing with these games yeah it's like
every evening we're sitting here and
doing a video and it's a draw you think
you wanna know what are they doing there
yeah but ok let's do let's do the game
but so okay so not 6e free now he's six
yeah we got this is the third white game
for Boris and we've got ya the same
opening again idea three and a six this
kind of semi Slav chevening coline
hybrid here and Misha really seems to
yeah if I've chosen this as his main
defense here and okay I don't think he
needs a reason at the moment to to
deviate you got relatively comfortable
draws up to now so why should black
change a thing and it's up to why to
come up with something something I'm
actually surprised that again we see the
c3 line and not like Knight f3 yarn
whatever something else get deafened
also sometimes place 1c for other moves
so yeah yeah okay but he tries some
Quincy to know yeah I think Quincy to um
well allow
actually very resourceful play I thought
to announce credit to try and exploit
the Queen and potentially leave them
with a week pull which he even uses a
pawn sacrifice later so the Queen might
be able to be used on the c5 that's made
uncomfortable for why and yeah that
seems to be the black plan to eat it
plays very energetically against Quincy
too yeah I played rc5 now which is Sir
maybe the main move from nowadays adjust
to explain briefly what's the idea of
Quincy too because it has an idea if if
black but wouldn't play c5 if you would
turn play let's say night be to g7 just
just the normal kind of move that you
tend to play then why'd I think
speculating here we'll play b3 and try
to develop its Bishop to be too if we
remember the first two games we had this
situation where black hair went Bishop
before early and then white needed to go
Bishop to d2 because he couldn't really
play Bishop b2 but now he actually could
yes and white would have a nice
ammonia's development now this kind of
attacks on c3 a dot so not so dangerous
right before you have 53 and you're just
in time yeah get rid of the night yes
yeah oh so that the idea so so black
black can play in this way it's not
super terrible but it's maybe more for y
than the other games so c5 is really the
as you said the most energetic way to
trying to open up the seafoam wear white
screen is located a bit prematurely in a
way so so yeah no way yeah so it's a bit
like tarish you know the fans yeah its
terrorist terrorist defense with a tempo
down mm-hmm mike has lost a move this is
actually a pretty common theme here in
this opening if white for example which
has been played against me a couple of
instead of Quincy to my place move like
a for this is also sometimes played
trying to prevent b5 and like also can
place in 65 and goes into this kind of
tirage ah the chapel down but white has
played the ridiculous move a for which
just weakens before and very often this
kind of delayed c5 with the tempo less
can be very effective because why this
extra moves yeah hurt a bit in a way
yeah so it's quite similar in the game
c5 is a loss of campbell from formal
point of you but it really addresses the
yeah the key points in the position and
also it simply allows 96 which is of
course a good square for the night yeah
so here c takes d5 was played not
minding liberating this Bishop white has
his eye on that d5 pawn potentially will
target d5 soon yeah he wants to be our
galaxy isolated pawn that it's most
likely going to emerge in the center mm
so visually towards very logical because
later there could be a bishop f free to
target defined but also yeah Bishop d3
might even run into at some point c4 I
don't know Bishop kept the bishop is not
very well placed on d3 for combating the
d5 pawn it is about to happen you want
to have routine one with direct pressure
and also oh yes three as you mentioned
yes so but you should be three yeah we
should be free now even by running to 96
or c4 but right so yeah this looks very
standard I think this audience has been
played before they mentioned this in the
broadcast briefly this is a known
position so castles so logical a 96 yeah
and our work do you are now this also
makes sense okay so i said Queen's pawn
gang after C takes d4 black has got that
I select Queen's pawn which looks as
though
the blockade is reasonable but um black
is going to gain a tempo on the rooks
now after Knight takes rook takes Bishop
c5 what I think move a tempo yeah ok so
rook d1 now ok um there's um so what do
you think of this position it it looks
as though this bishop could be a menace
on this diagonal if whites not careful
about f2 maybe something like be four is
quite dangerous sometimes but on the
other hand this this pin black kind of
gets his queen away from that default
now with Queen e7 also i guess this
Queens threatening bishop indirectly so
yeah Queenie seven not only gets the
rook away from the x-ray but protects c5
but it also has a cunning porn
sacrifices are about to see in general
what what's pretty I'm getting away
amazing here on that black is some
better developed here considering that
he played 65 which you would associate
with a lot of time but if you look at it
now black has got almost minor pieces
developed between only seven so it's
ready to to castle and put rocks on
let's say CA 10 d 8 yes and it is a bit
quicker than Wyatt and I think the main
problem here for widest um left the kind
of slow plans that you usually would
play let's say if you have time you
would play stuff like be three Bishop b2
you should be 3 92 94 on this kind of
stuff and it tooks awful lot of time and
it takes an awful lot of time and black
will get quick counter play if you want
if you go b3 and in this knight on c3 is
loose on c3 yeah lookbooks the age we
should before you get get rest here so
whether the main point obviously which
would you see in the game is so that
white goes snider Bishop e3 checking the
pawn and now there has been a game which
leg voted in the
podcasts or I don't know i somehow I
learned that Brooke the eight has been
played here before yeah at Grand Master
game which is kind of yeah the normal
move protecting the fire and I don't
think even this position would hold so
many horrors for black he looks pretty
solid d for an idea to get rid of her
the porn all right yes that's not just
the defensive move the ain't butter
Anand so he plays Nelly energetically
very energetically not even because
sometimes you can make your pieces
passive if you try and let them protect
to weakness yeah so making a kind of
gambit now he does castles yeah this is
of course the move you want to play it
besides the fact that it loses a pawn
and it turns out that yeah losing a pawn
I didn't really matter so much here yeah
and therefore took it I think if you
don't take it I don't see how you yeah
hopefully get to get your pieces odd
well maybe black has the option of using
this rook if needed yeah look at F 2d
eight and then yell on here she'll be
more comfortable in it to have photo
yeah with d 4 is a potential threat
still so yeah blimey so so why it's kind
of unfortunately it seems wise hasn't
got that Pleasant a position then if
he's forced to accept so kind of gambit
here yeah but this I think of bishops
passive um volta might sound porn now I
think I think girlfriend did see that
night xt5 doesn't lead to anything but
the problem is that what would you do to
play for one here um you need to
consider yeah it's not easy because the
queen is somewhat bad on c2 let's say
you play be three just just for instance
you know to try to develop and maybe I
move like oopsy eight simply we should
be too yeah there should be two and
now the question is should befall this
is annoying like pinning then you can
maybe go Quinn d3 it's not such a big
deal I'm gonna shop or should like just
play up the eighth now maybe maybe Luke
th because you want to play an ID to now
but you cannot because leg discovers
should take see 3 yeah Knight to Bishop
e3 and it's hard to how to prevent you
follow I'm just wondering in this
position this Bishop might be awkward
I'm wondering about g6 Bishop f5 but I
know you're weakening the dark squares
soon as you play juice yeah visually I
fact is this an idea though it would be
nice to get a temple on I think if you
if you're able to play d4 you then then
it's over anyway in terms of playing for
any advantage and you need to need to be
cautious even but like somewhat superior
development doesn't get you into trouble
yeah so yeah I know 90 x 25 it doesn't
lead to a most inspiring position no but
the other stuff really looks like only
white can get into trouble yeah so yeah
it took the porn what can you do so we
got this position now where pieces are
exchanged 25 and now looks he ate yes
and now this limited white options here
um isn't have a kiss if he doesn't do
what he played which is Bishop d2 what
is he didn't hear um you can easily
drift into a very very awkward position
if he doesn't immediately tries to to
get his pieces into play will be the
most painful with beef be free I wonder
that Bishop e3 or just Bishop d4 mix /
yeah the rook oh yeah it's just horrible
but it's it's hard too hard to suggest a
move let's say that's a queen bee three
maybe to get out of the out of the
discovery
of the bishop just just to try and try
and move and now what's black play here
I mean it's obvious that black guys got
some compensation but i think this rook
the attention i just is probably quite
dangerous um i'm not sure the edges are
donezo I'd be a good move I'm just
trying to I'm just looking if there's
some something even more aggressive
available I don't see it don't see it
but exist I mean it's like Bishop d2
that be disaster one that takes I'm
Brooke di here yeah this is quite
embarrassing yeah yeah maybe luke cage's
is good white doesn't have much else
then maybe taking on d 8 hmm awesome I
don't know it was like a ch3 or
something this this last saw this enough
compensation why it's just this Bishop
is just the nightmare yeah the problem
is not compensation the problem listen
smite may be bad for white the this is a
problem I think he wouldn't mind to take
a pawn if you think so this position is
still solid but here you could easily
imagine white being very worse yeah if
the Rope gets on into the 221 in a way
maybe your threat he is a move like we
need six or something trying to just
trying to get rid of the Queen and then
infiltrate on d1 yes actually I did I'm
do a bit with engine check earlier and
there was this variation I found well in
some other point of the game where even
after you know Queens came off rook d1
check ya akhi move rock h1 a black had
this nasty pin then on bishop and that
was enough compensation it was better
for ya even so they could put it on the
board just to show because it's a really
useful motif to know let's say white
goes h3y to make yourself a bit bit of
room here for the king 26 Queen takes c6
looked you one check of course King h2
and then then checks and now it's a can
be quite an issue to get this piece
developed yeah well maybe be 39 in this
position I wonder about the check to
false G freezer so weaken the second row
back because then if it should be today
you have the check yard ever check check
g3 Bishop g5 our Bishop b5 even more
painful to stop we should be too yeah
this kind of stuff and it's hard to see
how white get some get rid of the rope
maybe you can even go maybe you can go
kingi to f3 to you too I mean it's time
because of this that maneuver so let's
see if it's black player Bishop see free
yeah this is the very direct but are
also very good what continuation yeah
you're right yeah this is something what
needs to water this is kind of the
danger in this position your back rank
is a bit weak and you simply don't have
a few pieces out yeah so Brooke a c8
sort of yeah maybe forces y2 to play
with what he played it's some it also
what what girl phone said in the press
crunch was Letty he tried to make lines
work where he wrapped the porn and I
mean not only grab it but also keep it
hmm but he said he's only he's the only
one risking something they are not even
risking a little so on Bishop Ditullio
this is just the best move judy has this
is a neat move in many respects a ghost
it gets a symmetrical porn structure
unfortunately which isn't very cloud
crowd-pleasing after Bishop takes III so
he's giving a porn back but is now
getting this very nice Bishop c4 at
least is bishop is now usefulness rooks
ready to yell to beat to be used and in
fact is Queen visually has an aggressive
square as well to make use of yeah yeah
yeah well this is seven
the kind of variation where white
doesn't have any problems at all and
maybe he's even got some a little little
bits of little bit of an advantage not
it's not too dramatic but the bishop one
sees reassess 5-piece nicely protected
blocking the C file and you've got this
idea of Queen a5 route 27 and well it's
it's a little bit a little bit of
something not yeah not much but at least
why doesn't risk anything and still chem
can try a bit but ok which is maybe the
best defender that there is so it's hard
to hard to beat him yeah Bishop b6 was
played on now Queen f5 which seems to
create a major France of rook d7 for
example yeah yeah so black needs to
attend to this so he plays actually our
queen e 6 okay and the Queen arm now
just goes to F free so maybe b7 could be
vulnerable in some variations but also
g7 look side as well in some lines and
this next move seems to want to blunt
this Bishop yeah exactly wants to wants
to avoid any nasty business on g7 hmm so
um this is certainly an I'm
recommendable move here f6 you need to
be cautious all the time to to weaken
your king but it's it's not that white
can can make any use of this and it's
just more important to to get rid of
potential threats on g7 yeah so um looks
like a fine move and now h4 which gate
back row issue but also this H Phi
matrix might be useful but it didn't
turn out that useful in game actually
yeah it's kind of using all your unit
sir to to make something happen here so
it uses h4 actually here is where the
game became
beggar exciting for me because on the
live commentary stream Kasparov joins
viddler Peter Svidler for the commentary
Angus wife actually predicted this next
move Queen c6 they're basically saying
if they get the heavy pieces off black
should have no problems here and Queen
c6 sort of sets immediate questions for
white of you know for things like maybe
rook da this this pins quite useful hmm
yeah yeah if he wants to play rugby
18x10 term exchanging all those so heavy
pieces and then it's really nothing it's
a it's nothing anyway but we need to be
a bit cautious actually I on my engine
analysis though I did some with Houdini
I'm there was a sort of embalm variation
I kind of alkyne gun construction of
rook a d1 rook d free and Quinn d1 so
when the Queen's behind two rooks is
alec lines gun it seemed to think that
gave want a small tiny advantage but I
don't think there's anything a big deal
about it Michael I'm here exactly just
unlock do you 10 or what it lectures
place realty aid is there something bad
happening might not be in this exact
position it does look as i wrote the
eight simplifies quite safely doesn't
there yeah yeah because this Bishop is
supporting what the eight as well so I
don't know it says suddenly as good as
the game I guess it's not nothing bad
happening to white here takes lots of
moves are of doubtful quality to to get
you get you into trouble here with white
now what why does just it's just equal
hmm just the same I sent the game so
would it played was more exciting age
five so is that as though h6 might be a
fret at some point undermining these two
yeah yeah look the edge just chop
everything off here and now we get this
position where a black girl
allows this split pawns yes but but
xpath gave if h6 this isn't such a hot
move here what was played in actually
rookie one but if h6 black has just g5
or even g6 because here this porn if
it's taken what there's at least two
moves which are interesting Bishop takes
f 2 with the idea of a cafe or just rook
d2 looks looks good as well with but
maybe I don't know what's absolutely
best and just look fa Todd sauce mmm
[ __ ] effect Brooke a fine that's
another might as well as that yeah it's
interesting at least am I mean rogue f2
and rocky t2 and takes on f2 was fine
art so this doesn't look so bad also if
you're willing please it could be risky
though you need to be cautious in a
position yeah this pawn your your sort
of any cage there's white let's let's
say yeah I can move from not sure where
but let's say it to h2 and then I move
like look everyone yeah this could be
getting dangerous for the black king
yeah like Bishop e7 will get it made yes
so actually black I don't know what the
exact reputation is of yeah maybe maybe
maybe this tag on effort or f2 or up t
two of those looks fine it seemed sir
seems better alright so if we take that
because actually h6 is vulnerable here
is that yeah so yeah this is just
nothing like the idea yeah for nothing
and c6 is protected as well so that's
that's not good in fact that might offer
the advantage over g6 then the Fatiha
item that the rooks attacking
immediately h6 so g5 might be I think
it's marthe noted one a strong move hair
yeah black threats king f 76 and taking
this thing yeah there's also that as
well isn't that yeah you need to it's
not that why this is in danger but it's
something if you don't really want to
play if you try to to get something
but well rookie one it's just normal
here yep so that the invasion points
covered elegantly with kf7 now seeming
you know I suppose he's done a and he's
going to do be followed by sees done I
to be is playing G for it does support
that but it does mean this pawn might be
vulnerable and and of course with with
e7 guarded now our black can get away
with this next move Bishop d4 without
any problem because if route d1 there's
Bishop takes f to that be a disasters
and though no useful pin there yeah so
this g4 is exposed as a weakness and
actually the engines have it is almost
dead ii call on evaluation now this is
here and me it's quite sure it just is
what god can you do it yeah it's just
visual basis of the symmetrical pawn
structure and and of course the massive
simplifications um but yeah this is this
ending here so take stakes at brooke d
for it is close to being completely
molds nothing but to really demonstrate
what could happen sorry out what could
happen here so this this is where they
agree to draw yeah yeah i think this is
some drawn in more than one way let's
see what what's the most are the most
accurate way well i think if you want to
try anything at all then it would know
must be f three here to cover this
otherwise black just takes you for yeah
so and now you know it's a question I
don't think you want to want to play em
up
to move here but you can just play work
T 1 and rookie to right all right yeah
win this was the check sorry yeah much
stronger than Rudy to just yak stupid i
was also single just see to it you can
just just grab this pawn and i'm
actually be a pawn up here yeah again ok
gets it back with lo que three it's
nothing I don't know there will be six
now yeah this was actually stupid yeah
yeah so we can't eat corn actually play
every that's an important note then so
why would perhaps have to play rook
takes c6 the LG 42 drop um and black
yeah you can play if I if you can play
okay for prod looks a bit strange but
Yunis as possible if I've maybe just
just advancing this pawn you can always
play date for covering in trouble
started also what you fire for taking a
huge fire yeah yeah it's a very George
proposed in the balance yes I'm but you
did have its points of drama this game
should we do a quick review then oh yeah
there's got ok for ok so I'm a variation
a new variation with Quincy to which was
pounced on energetically by annas back
to his great credit making it into a
sort of very active gambit um butter
white countered this by to sucking the
porn back so we ended up with a
symmetrical porn structure unfortunately
for the crowds watching this game all
around the world symmetrical porn
structure White's pressure here after
Queen f5 was parried and Jesse with this
very good I do have f6 and Queen c6 this
useful pin and the h5 plan didn't seem
to have too much bite to it in terms of
h6 because black has resources
so wins that with some more heavy pieces
coming off and the brook ending offering
not much okay I agree yeah it's a very
it's very precise David unfortunately
it's not that makes you yeah get off the
train bottles and celebrate but but what
can you do it it's all happens if um if
both players don't take so much risk you
cannot really blame blame the black
sites in those games really in those
matches you know you have often got the
tour get get this talk like and play
playful winners black and so on well to
be honest this is just [ __ ] like
it's fine in those matches to to have a
fine solid position may be trying to
play on counter text if why does
something stupid but as Wai them you
need to press somehow and yeah this
really didn't work out here nah still
very nice i guess preparation offering
this sacrifice on d5 white um was summer
forced to take this pawn and after this
is it's just about nothing so i really
hope that that girl found in his next
white game will try something yeah a bit
more ambitious i think well if you go
quickly to move for him just just
quickly um let's say he goes instead of
e 393 here then anid usually plays some
e6 here and he also plays details before
but usually plays a six and then Bishop
g5 for instance here and then then an
are not only plays h6 y'know audibles
and then bishop h4 and you get to
completely crazy world position where
you can really play for something it's a
yet this kind of d take c4e form
ephone g5g g 3 p-5 and both players have
played this with both colors does this
phone involving danko radio match
between the States and the USSR
Botvinnik now this is the end this is
the this is not about winning this is
the entire Moscow um it looks a bit
similar but here in this move on a white
doesn't have the chance to two
sacrifices piece on g5 Lackey cannon in
the pod Vinick so this is a real pawn
sacrifice from White's point of view but
like has played the most b5 and g5 it is
first eight moves so you can also
already see that his King won't ever
safe even in the near future so this is
the kind of yeah open open fist fight
can't with Inquisition yet yeah what
this I don't know yeah if you want to
win this match maybe you need to do to
get into something which involves the
the idea also of losing once in a while
what it may be you win something at time
so yeah I was more expecting something
along these lines to happen but maybe he
just says um okay we're playing those
drawers we have 12 games in total and I
can take those risk still on in game I
don't know game 9 gave me 11 if you
strike a blow their it's hard to imagine
that the other player will come back
then yeah so it has a point from a
tactical from a match tactics point of
view it is just not too great to watch
him alright so let's so for some more
excitement the next game is tomorrow no
II am it's a it's um it's on Sunday
right right yeah I think rest I because
this was game six yeah so two games than
rest day so yep I crest I tomorrow yeah
maybe he needs to try and stop what I'm
playing against this a success online it
really seems so like Russia has got it
all worked out and his heart
beat you it was quite amazing in the
broadcast today they got as you
mentioned to a master suite lung in
there and he actually said that and it
was very surprised they actually said
that he never managed to win the
classical time control game against
Arnold blimey and this is quite
something because they play against each
other for like 16 17 years and never won
em you want [ __ ] games or a rapid game
maybe never a blindfold game never in a
two hour forty moves kind of game and
this shows that yeah which is obviously
really tough defender and if you've got
a really strong defender you maybe you
need to use some other weapons and this
kind of featherweight style yeah yeah
laughter so it's not medicine Mendes you
chure criticism it's just it's it's hard
to imagine that that it can win win this
match in this way and never dokie Anand
besides Game three didn't have so much
as right also it shows that black with
very very thorough preparation has got
really good equalizing possibilities so
how to get something nowadays with white
so you all right okay um hope our
YouTube viewers have got something out
of the commentary here and thanks
everyone for watching are things just
explained Chris okay so we'll be back
after tomorrow I hope that helps or 2
i'm gonna shop location actually i'd
hope to have decent internet access so
that we can continue this comentarii
itself ok ok alright thanks everyone
okay Chism